one of the other big stories over the
last week or so
was the appearance by dr robert malone
on the joe rogan podcast
and he talked about something called
mass formation
psychosis which i'll let him explain in
just a moment uh but
we all sort of know what it is right
like if you say the phrase mass
formation psychosis it's mass it's a lot
formation it's something that's kind of
moving psychosis a little craziness it's
sort of what we all can sort of tell
without being experts has been happening
over the last two years right everyone
is just sort of nuts and nothing is
really true or real or at least you got
to really try to pilfer some reality out
of all of the nonsense and that the
people in charge say joe biden
dr fauci et cetera have lied to us all
along so before we get into mass
formation psychosis i'm going to show
you some lies we've got a compilation
during 2021 we should be able to
manufacture a lot of vaccines and and
that vaccine
a key goal is to stop the transmission
to get the immunity levels up so that
you get almost no almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever
everyone who takes the vaccine is not
just protecting themselves but reducing
their transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal we can kind of almost
see the end we're vaccinating so very
fast our data from the cdc today
suggests um you know that that
vaccinated people do not carry the virus
don't get sick now we know that the
vaccines work well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person a
vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else it cannot use a vaccinated
person as a host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this essentially vaccines
block you from getting and giving
the virus fully vaccinated people
are at a very very low risk of getting
covet 19.
therefore
if you've been fully vaccinated you no
longer need to wear a mask when people
are vaccinated they can feel safe that
they are not going to get infected okay
so everything that those people to that
catchy tune
were telling you there over the last two
years was basically a lie or complete
misinformation or disinformation or they
didn't know what they were talking about
or they're
misinforming you lying whatever phrase
you want to use for political purposes
or something but these are the people in
charge right this is joe biden does he
know what he's saying or is he just
handed a script and he reads it or is he
intentionally lying was fouchy lying
when he said that my favorite one is
the actress on msnbc rachel maddow
because she reads off the teleprompter
with such
certitude such she's so sure of exactly
what she's reading and that's exactly
what's gonna happen and she sits there
and it's msnbc and she's very sure of
something that's completely wrong
completely wrong so these people have
lied and misinformed all of us all and
what's interesting think about i do a
daily show here right i do a five day a
week show how come i didn't lie about
all that stuff this whole time how come
i was like hey if you want to get it get
it maybe we should have some more info
talk to your doctor make a choice for
yourself so when you see all these lies
all the time don't pretend that everyone
lied all along and we're gonna have to
think about when this is all done when
this is all done and one day it will be
what do we do with these people like i'm
not for throwing them in the gulag like
they'd love to do with us but should
they be like sort of shamed out of
public society bill gates what does bill
gates have to do with all of our public
health congratulations for creating
paint on windows in 1995 great guy bill
gates but you don't run my life
anywho it gets even better here's cdc
director walensky you know this woman
we've shown many clips of her
she's basically admitting that the
vaccines just don't work
our vaccines are working exceptionally
well they continue to work well for
delta with regard to severe illness and
death they prevent it but what they
can't do anymore is prevent transmission
so if you're going home to somebody who
has not been vaccinated to somebody who
can't get vaccinated somebody who might
be immuno suppressed or a little bit
fail uh frail somebody who has
comorbidities that put them at high risk
i would suggest you wear a mask in
public indoor settings
oh lady okay so they work well but they
don't prevent transmission what's also
interesting is
they not only don't prevent transmission
but we know that it doesn't really
matter if you're relatively young and
healthy whether you're vaccinated or not
and you get covered because people are
recovering especially from the omicron
variant i know plenty of people who were
vaccinated who had kobe the exact same
time as me and they kept saying because
they've been vaccinated and i got the
two vaccines and i was boosted and i had
87 shots and everything else it didn't
hit me that hard right like so that's
their own version of it that's the thing
that everybody as elizabeth warren and
cory booker and as all of these public
people uh have gotten it and i'm sure
aoc is going to say the same thing i got
the boosters i did what i was supposed
to do i got shot so i didn't get that
sick well there are plenty of people who
didn't
do those things who figured out other
treatments right or maybe just took some
advil whatever it is that they decided
to do who also aren't that sick so
there's no real any any evidence on any
of that but the very people who are
telling us that masks work are now
telling us masks don't work the people
who are telling us that the vaccine
stops transmission and you can then go
out and live your life are now telling
us the complete reverse and that brings
me to mass formation psychosis so dr
robert malone was on the joe rogan
podcast and he is one of the creators of
the mrna vaccine and he went on for a
couple hours i'm sure many of you have
seen some clips of this already and he
talked about what is happening here not
really at the disease level but what is
happening to all of us collectively
mentally take a look basically european
intellectual inquiry into what the heck
happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
and how did that happen
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society
that has become decoupled from each
other and has free-floating anxiety in a
sense that things don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events on one small point just
like hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
and one of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as
their leaders the ones typically that
come in and say you have this pain and i
can solve it for you i and i alone
okay can fix this problem for you okay
then they will lead they will follow
that person through it doesn't matter
whether they lie to them or whatever the
data are irrelevant and furthermore
anybody who questions
that narrative is to be immediately
attacked they are the other
this is central to mass formation
psychosis and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before
2019 everybody was complaining the world
doesn't make sense blah blah blah
um and we're all isolated from each
other we're all on our little tools
we're not connected socially anymore
except through social media
and then this thing happened and
everybody focused on it
that is how mass formation psychosis
happens
and that is what's happened here
who sounds more truthful dr robert
malone is he calmly explains that one of
the founders of mrna technology someone
who is a complete expert on
what we are all injecting ourselves with
right does he sound more honest or is it
rachel maddow reading off the
teleprompter is it joe joe rogan is it
joe biden
rogan's fine is it biden as he is
reading whatever they put in front of
him etc etc i think you guys know the
answer to that now i'm not going to sit
here and pretend that i'm an expert in
mass formation psychosis but malone's
pretty close to it and over the last two
years i think i've spent most of my time
on this show i think probably the main
reason you watch the show is to pilfer
some of that sanity from all of the
[ __ ] all of the lies that are
constantly thrown at us right brett
kavanaugh as a serial rapist the
covington kids are all racist kyle
rittenhouse is a white supremacist
murderer donald trump said very fine
people on both sides russia hoax like
all of this stuff that can cause a mass
formation psychosis a bunch of
misinformation fed to us from the
machine
that you then see something you might
find some little clip some crazy guy
online who might be able to counter some
of that information but you're the one
that feels crazy for having seen it
because so much of the machine is just
about peddling [ __ ] to control you
and mandate you do this and decide when
you can go out and everything else